énorme joie dé versailles et ce samedi
sur la pelouse de saint malo après
plusieurs mois en tête du championnat de
nationale 2 le fc versailles 78 validé
sa montée à l'échelon supérieur après sa
victoire en terre bretonne sur le score
de 2 à 1 dans le même temps chartres
seule équipe qui pouvait encore montée
s'est incliné face à caen a été plus que
la coupe de france en plus qui pue des
frères et
comptera plus que rempli pour les
versailles et cette montée en 3e
division espéré en début de saison est
une première historique pour le club à
cela il faut ajouter l'incroyable
parcours en coupe de france des joueurs
de la cité royale
éliminé au stade des demi-finales par
nice 2 0 après un match héroïque à
l'extérieur une épopée qui a conquis le
public français et a rempli la place du
marché à versailles une année de rêve je
pense que
l'équipe de
finale
une montée
en gamme
pour valider définitivement le titre de
champion de nationale 2 les versaillais
devons prendre le meilleur sur plabennec
le samedi 14 mai à domicile dans leur
stade mob auront l'occasion de marquer
encore plus l'histoire de ce club né
d'une fusion en 1989